seven bags yeah I'm not doing Andre no
laundry other Pickers wash machine
that's disgusting
eyeballs put my clothes way we put our
dolls I don't wait me it's just nasty
you know it's almost like you're gonna
be in prison it is and you can't talk to
anybody it's like being in a hole all
right tomorrow
you gotta get you prison smart I feel
like I am I can make the top prison food
which is the ramen noodles and tuna fish
it's absolutely amazing you need to take
lots of journaling books no you can't
write stuff down yeah can't take a book
bible to take the back thing you say
Richard not talking to my baby that's
hard
do you know how many times we talk a day
you know I can't go on a date with LEGOs
get out without call it log n so we'll
see that's gonna be hard
ya might know me know that my babies my
entire life and this is gonna be like a
struggle for me being gone from him for
like a day
what about 30 days I can already tell
that the hardest part about this whole
thing is going to see if I can be away
from my baby that we got this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]